wir sprechen heute auch ein bisschen die
ukraine ja ihr habt ja so viel theater
hier in europa und ich spreche jetzt
amerikaner nicht als deutsche
uns irgendwie ein bisschen weh was ich
gerade hier abspielt ja dass wir die
amerikaner weiter bekannt für
für
frieden zu schließen kriege zu beenden
ja und wir haben das ja erlebt wir sind
damals nach der nach 45 wir haben dass
wir in der schule erlebt wurde über die
nazi zeiten so das haben wir alles
mitbekommen und ich lebe jetzt in
beverly hills wo wir auch eine jüdische
community haben und die leute sprechen
oft darüber das darf nie mehr passieren
das darf nie mehr passieren was da war
in der nazi zeit und jetzt haben wir vor
der tür jetzt genau dasselbe wieder und
wir amerikaner wie wir leiden da
förmlich darum geht dass der baum macht
keiner was tun und ja ich spreche auch
als republikaner
freund von dem präsidenten wo man eine
frau noch lebte rahden und draußen
falschen aus und aber ist in amerika so
dass auch die demokraten sich
mittlerweile schon gegen den präsidenten
stellen das geht einfach nicht mehr
können nicht dass die leute in der
ukraine so leiden dass leute ermordet
werden gefoltert werden das geht einfach
nicht wir können das ich machen und das
ist schade dass ich da nicht abspielt
das ja nicht geholfen wird und jetzt
habe ich gerade gehört ja man versucht
irgendwie etwas zu regeln oder soda oder
eine pause zu machen das geht einfach
nicht mehr kampflos durchgezogen werden
und man darf sich ganz einfach nicht von
den rosa pressen wasser das geht einfach
nicht mehr das arme gemacht werde immer
wenn die auch atomwaffen haben wir
wissen dass er atomwaffen haben aber wir
dürfen uns nicht von den russen
erpressen lassen wir sind alle soldaten
wir können kämpfen und wir müssen den
kampf beenden und wir wissen der ukraine
helfen dessen freunde das sind menschen
ein wichtiger appel ein vehementer hp
von ihnen aber empfinden sie denn den
spot also die zustimmung für die ukraine
in amerikas größer als in deutschland
da ist ja auch richtig so die deutschen
die europäer müssen viel mehr mitziehen
ich weiß nicht warum deutschland ist so
zurückkehrt das sind unsere freunde sind
auch geschäftspartner ich weiß nicht
dass die deutsche schule angst haben die
deutschen turniers ohne angst gehabt
plötzlich ist also eine große angst und
man sieht dass von amerika aus sagt was
ist da in deutschland überhaupt los
warum machen die europäer nicht wir
müssen das ganz wir können uns nicht
erpressen lassen dürfen keine kriege
mehr geben menschen dürfen nicht mehr
leiden in europa da muss endlich schluss
mit zahlen und wir müssen hier in der
ukraine krisen müssen wir zeigen müssen
wir bis zeigen wir müssen ein standbein
haben wir müssen man sagen wir sind
soldaten und müssen das freikämpfen und
die ukraine machen mit wir müssen den
russen auf die füße treten ganz einfach
lassen sie uns das einmal mit der hunde
debattieren ich würde gerne herr
fleischhacker dazu bitten können sie das
nachvollziehen dass in amerika die
zustimmung scheinbar größer ist wenn man
den erzählungen horcht von herrn von
anhalt kann es auch sein dass europa
mehr zu verlieren hat als amerika aber
auch die handelsbeziehungen zum beispiel
beim gas andere das ist ganz bestimmt so
ich glaube das was die beiden ein und
das war ja möglicherweise sagen viele
auch strategische fehler dass man schon
von beginn an gesagt hat die nato jetzt
sich jedenfalls nicht involvieren in
diesem konflikt viele sagen ja es wäre
wichtig gewesen das ist wo potenzial
aufrechtzuerhalten wenn man schon intern
sagt wir werden dort nicht aktiv in den
krieg eintreten als nato oder auch als
vereinigte staaten dass man das intern
sich ausmachen kann aber das ist keine
gute strategie ist das zunächst schon
öffentlich zu sagen weil sie einen
angreifer und agresso ermutigt so mehr
einzugehen ansonsten glaube ich dass
seine haut kommt natürlich schon der ist
das bei allen auswirkungen die jetzt
jenseits des schlachtfeldes da sind also
vor allem bei den ökonomischen
auswirkungen natürlich das klingt dann
immer so grausam aber natürlich amerika
letztendlich profitiert es wird jetzt
mehr amerikanisches flüssiggas gekauft
werden das immer dreimal so teuer war
wie russische pipeline gas es wird
wahrscheinlich den militärisch
industriellen komplex in amerika nicht
besonders stören dass die man sagen die
waffenproduktion wieder sehr große an
läuft also alles was außerhalb des
schlachtfeldes passiert ökonomisch vor
allem ist natürlich etwas was europa
sehr viel mehr betrifft und europa die
vereinigten staaten betrifft nur nicht
so sehr sondern letztendlich glaube ich
muss sagen profitieren sie auch durch
julian profitieren die vereinigten
staaten fand im krieg
also ich glaube die vereinigten staaten
als land profitieren davon nicht also
natürlich gibt es jetzt gerade
rüstungskonzerne die auch der
bundesregierung viele angebote machen
und sagen wir haben da übrigens noch was
und das wollten wir schon immer mal
verkaufen insofern bin ich mir sicher
dass auch in vereinigten staaten einige
rüstungskonzerne sagen klar wenn waffen
gebraucht werden dann verkaufen wir
waffen und dann ist das gut ansonsten
glaube ich aber dass auch in die usa
eine große auch ukrainische community
beispielsweise da sind kanada noch
größer aber auch in der ukraine und
insofern gibt es da glaube ich finde ich
übertrieben aber ich denke millionenfach
familiäre verbindungen das land und ich
glaube dieser dieses emotionale was auch
in den staaten da ist ist eher dass man
sagt ja wie kann ein so was also auch
ich kenne jemanden der jemand aus der
ukraine kennt oder verwandte ist mit
denen und wie kann das sein dass die im
21 jahrhundert plötzlich in städten
leben die sind aus wie im zweiten
weltkrieg ja also ein kollege hat dass
ihr gesagt dass sie tatsächlich
teilweise so aus als wäre da eine
atombombe oder ähnliches anlagen war man
dafür nicht nur geschäft redet hier oder
geschäft wer profitiert wir reden doch
über menschen menschen wären noch
gefoltert und getötet hat ist und wer
den menschen zu helfen hervor einer ich
bin mir fast sicher würde ich jetzt
einmal sagen dass alle am tisch ist
furchtbar finden was in der ukraine
passiert und es ganz schlimm finden dass
der aggressor putin so handelt aber wenn
sie natürlich sagen in amerika da sind
alle stärker auch da dafür da muss man
natürlich schon fragen okay wie ist denn
die lage in amerika wie ist die lage in
deutschland und wir müssen auch sagen
die politiker in deutschland schwören
auch ein schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden und selbstverständlich müssen
wir auch darüber reden finde ich was ist
ökonomisch für deutschland bedeutet
sehen sie das anders ja also sie wollen
eine branchen eingereiht das ist ja doch
auch sie wollen sie lassen sich
erpressen von toten ja wenn ihr nicht
dann machen wir die atombombe das so
geht es ja nicht
ja aber wir denken nicht über geschäfte
in amerika wir sehen die bilder wir
sehen die bilder die aus dem amerika
nicht so viele in deutschland haben wir
auch ein größeres los als sie in amerika
wo die chefs von amerika aus wir
erzählen die bilder und wir sehen
grauenhaften und diese bilder dürfen
nicht mehr gezeigt werden die müssen weg
wir müssen frieden schaffen wir müssen
frieden schaffen und zusammen mit europa
die ukraine schon mit europa schaffen
dass die schaffen das die würden das
auch schaffen ohne amerika aber
deutschland hilft nicht die weiße warum
deutschland nicht hilft dann würde es
ohne amerika amerika würde europa
schaffen okay da würde ich gern noch mal
unseren militärexperte julian ridge
fragen ob das stimmt dass wir das nur
mit europa schaffen keiner ich würde ich
mir wünschen basis stimmt ich würde mir
wünschen dass es stimmt aber die praxis
ohne amerika sind wir hier nichts jaja
aber aber das ist mal wenn in russland
so lange krieg führt gegen die ukraine
und schafft das nicht innerhalb von
einer woche dann zeigt der russe doch
schwäche und das wissen wir doch da
wusste jetzt schwach ist mittlerweile
wir europäer können das alleine machen
ohne die amerikaner aber nun sind die
amerikaner ja da
was können wir ihre beine machen waffen
liefern was und liefern ganz einfach
moderne waffen liefern die ukraine die
haben nicht moderne waffen die brauchen
die waffen draufhauen macht die platte
die man die russen haben wir angefangen
ich die ukraine ein friedliches volk das
sind freunde warum sollen die leidenden
menschen und verbannten wohnhäuser
krankenhäuser schulen bombardiert was
hat das mit soldaten zu tun was hat das
mit krieg zu tun haben das ist die
anderen was heißt plattmachen konkret
die anfahrt den krieg beenden und wenn
ihr das nicht wollt dann drauf haben so
ist es halt im krieg sehen wir mal die
ukraine haben jetzt so gelitten die ist
ein leidensweg gegangen für wochen jetzt
jetzt muss das auch beendet werden es
werden menschen sterben aber der krieg
muss beendet werden und da kann nur
beendet werden von den ukrainern und die
grünen müssen beliefert werden volle
oper mit modernen waffen also was eben
drauf frauen tatsächlich seltsam finde
ist ja da wird es auch bei mir später
darum gehen wie kann es sein dass es
gibt in europa wirklich 20 gut
ausgerüstete armee die schicken zusammen
nicht halb so viel schwere waffen wie
die usa die usa schicken jetzt gerade 90
artilleriegeschütze die extrem wichtig
sind für die ukraine aus deutschland
kommen sieben aus sondern kommen fünf
aus norwegen 18 wird es sie nicht
überraschen wenn bereits dass 80 prozent
der militärkapelle gesamten nato durch
im wesentlichen durch die vereinigten
staaten vereinigte königreich und fdp
hergestellt werden muss das stimmt aber
anderen weniger als die hälfte dessen
auf das stimmt aber rein theoretisch
hätten wir nicht sieben panzerhaubitzen
sondern wir 120 davon wenn man sagt man
gibt 10 20 30 davon ab da wird der russe
nicht morgen von berlin stehen